uh
can i ask you uh in terms of um you know
the deep state and conspiracy theories
there's a lot of talk about so again
from an outsider's perspective
if i were just looking at twitter it
seems that at least ninety percent of
people in government are pedophiles
at 90 90 95 i'm not sure what that
number is
if i were to just look at twitter
honestly or youtube i would think
most of the world is a pedophile i would
almost feel like
right and if you don't fully believe
that you're a pedophile
yeah yeah i would start to wonder like
wait am i
like what am i a pedophile too like i'm
either a communist or a pedophile or
both i guess
uh yeah that's going to be clipped out
thank you internet
i look forward to your emails uh but
is there any kind of shadow
conspiracy theories that give you pause
or so the flip side the response to a
lot of conspiracy theories it's like
no the reason this happened is because
it's a combination of
just incompetence so where do you land
on
some of these uh conspiracy theories i
think most conspiracy theories are wrong
some are true and those are
spectacularly true
and if that makes sense yeah um i and we
don't know which ones
i don't know which one that's the
problem i think well i mean
look man i listened to your podcast i
think i was a huge
non-believer in ufos and now i've
probably never believed more in uf like
i
i believe in ufos like i'm very
comfortable
being like not only do i believe in ufos
like i think we're probably being
visited by an alien civilization
like and if you asked me that three
years ago i would be like you're out of
your [ __ ] mind like what are you
talking about
well listen to david fraber that's all i
have to say that's it
well i i have the sense that the
government has information that
hasn't revealed but it's not like
they're i don't think they're holding
there's like a green guy sitting there
exactly they just
they have seen things they don't know
what to do with so it's like
they're confused like they're afraid
yeah of revealing that they don't know
that's what i think it is right it's
revealing the yeah exactly
you don't know and then they're in the
process there's a lot of fears tied up
in that first
looking incompetent in the public eye
nobody wants to be
uh looked that way and the other is like
in revealing it
even though they don't know maybe china
will figure it out exactly
so like we don't want china to figure it
out first and so that
all those kinds of things result in
basically secrecy then
that damages the trust in institutions
on one of the most fascinating
aspects like one of the most fascinating
mysteries of humankind
of is there life intelligent life
out there in the universe so that's one
of them but there there's other ones
like uh
for me when i first came across actually
alex jones
was 911. yeah i remember like because i
was um
i was in chicago i was thinking like oh
[ __ ] are they gonna hit chicago too
that's what everybody was thinking yeah
everybody everybody was thinking like
what does this mean let's get what scale
what
i mean trying to interpret it and i
remember like
looking for information that's been like
what what happened what
and i remember not being satisfied with
the
quality of reporting and figuring out
like rigorous like
here's exactly what happened and so
people like alex jones stepped
up and others that said like there's
some shady [ __ ] going on
and it sure as hell looked like there's
shady [ __ ] going on
yes uh so like and i still stand behind
the fact that it seems like there's not
i there's not enough like it wasn't a
good job of being honest and transparent
and all those kinds of things
because it would implicate the saudis
let's be honest right and see that's
that's my conspiracy theories i'm like
yeah i think they covered up a lot of
stuff because they wanted to cover up
for the kingdom of saudi arabia like and
then
i mean that is that was a conspiracy
theory not that long ago i think it's
true i mean i think it's 100 true
you